[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild august
1965 eine warme Sommernacht im
Duisburger Stadtteil Großenbaum ein
junges Paar knutscht wild in einem VW
Käfer herum hier fühlen sich die beiden
ungestörter als irgendwo zu Hause bei
den Eltern aber während es im Innenraum
des Wagens zur Sache geht schleicht
jemand um den Käfer herum STT einen
Reifen auf der jetzt laut zischt das
Paar schreckt auf doch da wird schon die
Tür aufgerissen der Mann richtet sich
auf und verlässt das Fahrzeug wie wild
sticht der Unbekannte im Dunkeln auf ihn
ein dann flüchtet er die Frau und ihr
Freund entkommen mit dem Wagen aber
später stirbt ihr Freund an den
[Musik]
Verletzungen was für eine Horrorszene
willkommen zu einer neuen Folge unseres
täglichen Podcast ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasimir und
das ist ein Fall der empfindliche Hörer
verstören kann deshalb weisen wir gleich
am Anfang darauf hin dass in dieser
Geschichte sehr drastische Todesszenen
geschildert werden wer darauf sensibel
reagiert der sollte diese Folge lieber
auslassen die Begebenheit am Anfang
gehört zu einer Mordserie die schon mehr
als 10 Jahre zuvor begonnen hat und die
weitere 11 Jahre später noch viel
fassbare enden wird über dieses Ende
sagt ein Kommissar später das werde ich
nie vergessen wie wir die Tür vom
Kühlschrank aufgemacht haben und dann
stand da der Kopf des Mädchens unten auf
dem kühlschrankboden Stand Marions Kopf
mit zwei großen braunen Augen die einen
anguckten wenn man die Tür
aufmachte wir berichten heute von
Joachim Kroll der als ruhrkannibale in
die deutsche Kriminalgeschichte e
gegangen ist Joachim Georg Kroll wird
1933 als sechstes von neun Kindern in
eine Bergarbeiterfamilie geboren die
krolls Leben in der oberschlesischen
Stadt Hindenburg Joachim gilt von Anfang
an als schwächlich und nicht besonders
schlau er geht nur 5 Jahre zur Schule
der Vater erzieht die Kinder mit harter
Hand was nichts anderes ist als eine
Floskel für familiäre Gewalt den debilen
Joachim der kaum lesen trifft es
besonders oft nach der kurzen Schulzeit
muss er auf Bauernhöfen als Tagelöhner
arbeiten und hier biegt er schon falsch
ab seine ersten sexuellen Erregungen
spürt Kroll wenn Kühe und Schweine
geschlachtet werden er beginnt sich in
Stelle zu schleichen und sich an den
Tieren zu vergehen auch die Körper
geschlachteter Tiere benutzt er um sich
zu befriedigen noch während der Vater in
Kriegsgefangenschaft ist zieht die
Familie nach
Nordrheinwestfalen hier arbeitet Joachim
mal als Toilettenreiniger mal als
Hilfskraft im Bergbau
1955 stirbt seine Mutter und das ist
sicher kein Zufall dass er in genau
dieser Zeit seinen ersten Mord begeht
nach allem was man heute weiß ist dieser
allererste Mord nicht geplant viel mehr
versuchen sich Joachim damals gerade 22
Jahre alt und eine junge Frau namens
Irmgard strhl aus wahstäde an
einvernehmlichem Sex aber Joachim kommt
zunächst nicht zum Höhepunkt und rastet
aus er ersticht irmgart versümelt ihren
Körper und vergeht sich an der Leiche
der entstellte Körper wird in
Lüdinghausen im Kreis Kosfeld gefunden
ein Monster ist geboren dem geistig
zurückgebliebenen Joachim Kroll stehen
in seinem Berufsalltag hier in
Nordrhein-Westfalen keine geschlachteten
Tiere mehr zur Verfügung aber er hat
jetzt herausgefunden wie es ihn erregt
wenn er Mensch
zu seinen Opfern macht
1956 wird in Kirchhellen heute ein Teil
von Bottrop ein zwöfjähriges Mädchen
vergewaltigt und ermordet die
Ermittlungen führen ins Leere im Juli
1959 eskaliert krulz gewalthunger weiter
im Stadtpark von Essen vergewaltigt und
erwirkt er eine 16-Jährige danach
schneidet er mit dem Messer Streifen von
ihren Hüften und dem Hintern ab außerdem
verringern sich jetzt die Abstände von
krollz Wahnsinnstaten im April 1962
verschwindet aus Burscheid spurlos ein
12 Jahre altes Kind wenig später wird in
dienstlaken eine 13-Jährige vergewaltigt
und erwirkt keine zwei Monate später
tötet Kroll in Duisburg eine
zwölfjährige wieder werden Streifen aus
dem Körper geschnitten was genau geht in
Kroll bei all diesen Morden wohl vor
Kommissar Bern Jägers der Kroll Jahre
später viele Stunden lang verhört
beschreibt krolls Drang so Kroll wollte
hauptsächlich das Kribbeln wegbekommen
er suchte seine Opfer völlig wahllos aus
es war ihm irgendwann sogar egal ob sie
in der Nachbarschaft lebten oder nicht
hauptsache er hatte seine Geschichte
erledigt und das Kribbeln war weg anders
als anderen eitlen Serienmördern ist es
Kroll völlig egal wie sein modus
operandi nach außen wirkt laut Kommissar
Jägers geht es ihm nur um seine eigene
Lust ihm war wichtig seine Opfer sterben
zu sehen er wollte beobachten wie sie
die Augen verdrehen wie das Gesicht blau
anlief je nachdem wie er die Frauen und
Kinder
umbrachte das erste Mädchen z.B erstach
er andere erdrosselte er mit ihren
Halstüchern und BHs es gab kein Muster
nachdem Kroll agierte darauf legte er
keinen Wert das sind gruselige und im
Rückblick sicher zutreffende
Einschätzungen aber in den Jahren in
denen Kroll wieder und wieder mordet hat
die Polizei überhaupt keinen Plan im
Gegenteil bei insgesamt vier Morden
werden sogar unschuldige verhaftet einer
von ihnen kommt mit einem richterlichen
Schuldspruch ins Gefängnis mindestens
zwei der irrtümlich Beschuldigten
zerbrechen an dieser Schande und begehen
Selbstmord die Polizei muss man so
schonungslos sagen versagt jahrelang auf
ganzer Linie eine Schande ehrlich zumal
das M
weitergeht
1965 kommt es zum dramatischen Überfall
auf das Liebespaar im VW Käfer bei dem
Kroll den Duisburger Hermann Schmitz
ersticht September 66 Frau in Mall
erwirkt Ermittler Verdächtigen
fälschlicherweise ihren Freund Dezember
66 ein fünfjähriges Mädchen wird
vergewaltigt und in einem seeertränkt
mai 70 eine 13-Jährige wird erwirkt ein
Schuldiger wird festgenommen
1976 ein 10 Jahre altes Mädchen wird
erwirkt diese Aufzählung wirkt als
könnte sie immer so weitergehen und
weitergehen aber dann kommt der Sommer
1976 er hat eigentlich so schon genug
dramapenzial der Sommer 76 ist in
Deutschland einer der heißesten an den
sich die Menschen erinnern können
wochenlang fällt kein Regen den ern
vertrocknet bei 30° und mehr die Ernte
auf den Feldern außerdem herrscht
Terroralarm im Juni entführen Verbrecher
aus Palästina zusammen mit Raf Mördern
ein Flugzeug nach Uganda bei der
versuchten Befreiung sterben mehr als 50
Menschen Anfang Juli
1976 wird die kleine Marion Kettner aus
der Friesenstraße 3 in düsburg LA
vermisst sie war vorher mit zwei anderen
Mädchen auf den Spielplatz gegangen d
erst vi Jahre alt ist sucht die Polizei
sehr schnell mit einem Großaufgebot nach
ihr sogar ein Hubschrauber kommt zum
Einsatz hunderte Polizeibeamte hören
sich in der Nachbarschaft um andere
gehen mit Spürhunden durch die
Wohngegend wie sie später herausstellt
wurde Marion zuletzt mit einem Joachim
Kroll aus dem Nachbarhaus gesehen er
geht als netter kut und wird der Liebe
Achim genannt Kommissar Jägers
beschreibt ihn später als das
hutzelmännchen das sein linkes Bein
nachzieht als einsamen Spinner mit dem
man im Zweifel Mitleid hat während der
Suchaktion ahnt noch niemand von einem
Zusammenhang zwischen Marions
verschwinden und Joachim Kroll aber bei
ihren zahlreichen Nachfragen bei der
Suche von Haus zu Haus fällt den Beamten
etwas anderes auf in der Friesenstraße
11 ist seit Tagen ein Etagenklo
verstopft berichtet ein Meter sein
Nachbar Joachim Kroll habe ihm gesagt er
habe die Eingeweide eines geschlachteten
nichens herunterspülen wollen die
Polizisten rufen einen Klempner und sie
befragen
Kroll ich habe geschlachtet ein
Kaninchen bestätigt der versehentlich
habe ich wohl mit den innerreihen das
Klo verstopft Kroll lässt die Polizisten
in seine Wohnung es wird eine
Ortsbegehung des Grauens in der
Tiefkühltruhe liegen Päckchen mit
Menschenfleisch im Kochtopf auf dem Herd
befindet sich eine Brühe aus Möhren und
Kartoffeln
sowie eine kleine
Menschenhand mir kam nur der Gedanke
dass man einmal probieren müsste wie
Menschenfleisch schmeckt ich habe Hände
Füße und Arme in einen Kochtopf getan
mit Wasser begossen und gekocht ich
wollte einmal probieren wenn das Fleisch
geschmeckt hätte dann hätte ich die
ganze Leiche nach und nach aufgegessen
als es aber nicht schmeckte habe ich es
mir anders
[Musik]
überlegt zunächst untersuchen
Streifenbeamte den Tatort und und führen
erste Befragung durch vor dem Haus
versammeln sich immer mehr Nachbarn aus
der Friesenstraße es entsteht eine
explosive Stimmung wenn sie könnten
würden die Anwohner den lieben Achim
jetzt wohl lünchen die Polizei aber
schickt die aufgebrachten Leute nach
Hause schließlich übernimmt
kriminalobermeister Bernt Jägers den
Fall von dem wir ja bereits am Anfang
dieser Episode gehört haben er ist
damals 77 Jahre alt verheiratet Vater
eines siebenjährigen Sohnes bevor er K
Wohnung betritt haben die Kollegen ihn
natürlich
vorgewarnt trotzdem ist es ein Schock
das werde ich nie vergessen wie wir die
Tür vom Kühlschrank aufgemacht haben und
dann stand er der Kopf des Mädchens
unten auf dem kühlschrankboden Stand
Marions Kopf mit zwei großen braunen
Augen die einen anguckten wenn man die
Tür aufmachte es beginnen tagelange
Verhöre Jägers berichtet später in
Interviews mit dem Fokus und der neuen
ruhrzeitung das zunächst völlig
verschlossen ist ich merkte dass das ein
sehr zurückgezogener Mensch war der
immer allein war der seine
Lebensverhältnisse zwar geregelt hatte
aber der Tagesablauf war immer derselbe
dann habe ich mir gedacht wie fängst du
das an dadurch dass er sehr kontaktscheu
und zurückhaltenend war dachte ich ich
spreche mit ihm einfach mal über seine
Hobbys sein Leben achi merkte dass jetzt
mal jemand mit ihm über seine Problem
seine Verhältnisse redete Jägers lockt
Kroll also aus der Schmollecke und so
geseht der nicht nur den unfassbar
grausigen kannibalenmord an der
vierjährigen Marion sondern auch schon
einige der vorausgegangenen taten aber
er weiß Gedächtnislücken auf erinnert
z.B die Tatorte nicht mehr genau im
Verhör sagt Kroll ich weiß dass wenn ich
da wieder hinkomme ich euch zeigen kann
was ich gemacht habe und so fahren
Kommissar Jägers und sein Team mit dem
Serienmörder mögliche Tatorte ab an den
Haltepunkten wird er jeweils gefragt ob
ihm irgendwas bekannt vorkommt dann
orientiert er sich an der Vegetation und
findet tatsächlich oft die Orte früherer
Morde wieder bei Jägers Ermittlungen
wird noch mal deutlich wie schlicht der
Beschuldigte ist sein IQ beträgt gerade
einmal
76 wenige Tage nach der Aufklärung des
Falles wird die kleine Marion Kettner in
Duisburg la beigesetzt zur Trauerfeier
kommen hunderte paradetrich Kor nennt
den Mord die Tat eines vom Teufel
Besessenen Menschen am Freitag dem 5
oktober 1979 beginnt im Saal 201 des
Duisburger Landgerichts der Prozess
gegen Joachim Kroll nach der
Untersuchung von 14 Todesfällen wirft
ihm die Staatsanwaltschaft acht
vollendete Morde und eine versuchte
Tötung vor der Vorsitzende Richter Paul
Georg schimmann muss in dem Verfahren
klären ob der geistig beeinträchtigte
Angeklagte überhaupt schuldfähig ist er
muss damit klarkommen dass Kroll viele
seiner vernehmungsaussagen später
widerrufen hat und er muss sich durch
einen ganzen Wust von Morden und
falschen Verhaftungen kämpfen es dauert
151 Verhandlungstage bis schimmern sein
Urteil verkündet neunm lebenslang der
Menschenfresser von Duisburg die Bestie
vom Rhein wandert buchstäblich für den
Rest seines Lebens ins Gefängnis denn
Joachim Kroll stirbt am 1 Juli
1991 an einem Herzinfarkt in der JVA
Reinbach und damit sind wir am Ende
unseres heutigen falls wir danken euch
fürs zuhören und freuen uns wenn ihr
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei
seid wenn ihr Anregungen Lob Kritik oder
fallvorschläge für uns habt über die wir
hier mal berichten sollen dann schreibt
uns gerne eine E-Mail oder eine
Nachricht bei Instagram die Links dazu
findet ihr in den Show nototes bis zum
nächsten mal euer
und euer
Stefan dir hat diese Folge von T
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren Folgen rein
hier warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle
auf dich wie das Verschwinden von
Rebecca Reusch der Prozess gegen OJ
Simpson oder die Entführung von ursela
Hermann wir hören uns bei Tat
Deutschland